have you ever been gazing at a starry
sky when suddenly a bright dot glided
into you if it wasn't blinking then
you've had the distinct pleasure of
seeing one of mankind's greatest
collaborative feats with your own eyes
the International Space Station roughly
the size of a six bedroom house and
weighing more than 320 cars the
International Space Station is so large
that no single rocket could have lifted
it into orbit instead it was assembled
piece by piece
while hurtling through space at 28,000
kilometers per hour
laughing the earth once every 90 minutes
it all started when sixteen nations
signed the space station
intergovernmental agreement laying out
each partners expected contributions to
the ISS from modules and maintenance to
sharing information and finances at an
estimated 100 billion u.s. dollars the
space station would be the most
expensive object ever built the whole
world watched as a Russian rocket
launched the first module of the ISS
into the sky
Zaria meaning sunrise was equipped with
two solar panels and a propulsion system
that had the important task of keeping
the young station from crashing into the
earth by staying a safe 400 kilometers
away
the US Space Shuttle Endeavor followed
two weeks later carrying unity unknown
module to which other modules can be
connected and an international six
person assembly group then came says de
which brought communications and living
accommodations
ever since the International Space
Station's first tenants arrived it's
been continually occupied with more than
200 visitors spending an average of six
months on board astronaut Samantha
Christopher any holds the record for the
longest single space flight by a woman
at 199 days on the ISS 2001 saw the
arrival of Destiny the first of four
research modules where astronauts spend
approximately 36 hours a week conducting
extraordinary experiments in
microgravity their schedules are packed
with exercise two hours a day to fend
off muscle atrophy station maintenance
and repair and connecting with family or
all inspired minds around the world but
they still find time for fun with
regular movie nights and even shooting
the first music video in space destiny
also controls the seven jointed robotic
handed arm two capable of moving more
than 100,000 kilograms it's perfect for
unloading new arrivals from shuttles
2001 was a busy year for the space
station with the addition of quest the
main airlock forced roles outside and
Pierce appear for Russian spacecraft to
dock including the ever ready urgency
escape vehicle Soyuz then on February
1st 2003 after delivering research
modules to the ISS the space shuttle
Columbia exploded and
tragically killing the set a member crew
on board
after a four-year hiatus work quickly
picked up pace with the addition of more
hubs airlocks docks and an observation
cupola for stunning 360-degree views of
our world and beyond other critical
components included platforms and
trusses to support radiators that direct
all of the heat generated by the
station's electronics into space and
solar panels that are efficient enough
to power 55 homes it took 10 years and
over 30 missions but finally the
International Space Station was complete
coinciding with the u.s. space shuttle
programs retirement the space station
continues to serve as an incredible
model for international collaboration
this year two people began a one-year
stay on the ISS allowing scientists to
study the long-term physical and
psychological effects of being in space
which would prove useful for
increasingly ambitious space travel like
trips to Mars over its lifetime we've
learned an immense amount scientifically
but also about our capacity to work
together and accomplish truly remarkable
acts